- [Carter] The average baby
will go through over 3,000
diapers in a single year.
At around 70 to $80 a month,
the cost of these diapers
will set a family back
nearly $1,000 a year.
And right now, this essential
is getting more expensive
for millions of Americans.
In March, diaper manufacturer
Kimberly-Clark announced
that it would be raising prices on many
of its products, including diapers.
And then competitor
Procter & Gamble announced
it would be doing the same.
For families with multiple children,
these price hikes could add up to hundreds
of dollars more per year.
- These price increases are happening
on household goods, on food, on gas.
Not only is it an amount that adds up,
it's an amount that comes in addition
to everything else costing more.
- [Carter] So what's causing diaper prices
to rise so dramatically?
It has a lot to do with the prices
you're seeing here, and here.
(lively music)
♪ I'm a big kid now ♪
- [Narrator 1] Parents are
more likely to choose Luvs.
- [Narrator 2] Pampers, the number one
pediatrician recommended brand.
- [Narrator 3] We're Huggies,
we've got just what you need.
- [Carter] It may look
like there are a lot
of options to buy diapers
but in reality, there are less
than what it may seem.
Only two companies control about 80%
of the US disposable diaper industry:
Procter & Gamble and Kimberly-Clark.
The same two companies
that announced price
hikes earlier this year.
- It means these companies
are less vulnerable to competition.
- [Carter] Sharon Terlep
reports on consumer products
for The Wall Street Journal.
- If P&G makes a decision on pricing,
that might drive the whole market,
whether it's up or down.
They don't have the concern as much
of having higher prices
and then having their
customers go somewhere else.
- [Carter] Most disposable
diapers are made
with layers of blended materials
to increase absorbency,
including this fluffy part,
which is made from wood pulp.
Just a few months ago,
lumber prices were through the roof,
powered by low mortgage rates
and demand for home improvement projects
that drove a suburban building boom.
This lifted the price
of wood, including pulp,
which in turn drove up costs
for diaper manufacturing.
- Costs of logging have escalated due
to the inputs at that
stage in the value chain,
namely the labor and the logistics
and the equipment associated
with felling trees.
- [Carter] David Garfield is a consultant
who has worked in the
consumer products industry
for almost three decades.
- And those increases in costs
do ripple through the
production of pulp and paper.
- [Carter] But one of
the biggest commodities
driving the price of
diapers is the same one
that is running your car.
- Oil price is soaring,
an OPEC-fueled rally
sending crude prices higher,
now up about 20% just over the last month.
- [Carter] As prices
have risen at the pump,
so have costs to produce diapers.
- Some of those ingredients or materials
that are incorporated into diapers
are derived from petroleum.
And so with the increase in price
of the barrel of oil comes an increase
in the material that
goes into making diapers.
There's also the knock-on effect
of diesel fuel prices up,
which impact the transportation costs,
as well as the material costs.
- [Carter] Petroleum or crude oil
is the same raw material used
to make sodium polyacrylate.
This is a polymer that's used in diapers
to help make them more absorbent.
It's what these absorption
beads are made out of.
Back in February, a winter
storm pummeled Texas,
forcing many petrochemical
manufacturing plants
to shut down, including those
that make acrylic acid,
a compound in sodium polyacrylate.
The extreme weather caused
acrylic acid shortages
for months, which drove up the price
of sodium polyacrylate.
This contributed to the
rising costs of diapers.
- Part of it was this piling-on effect.
It was just one more thing
on top of everything else.
But it made this material
harder to come by
and so at the time
when I spoke to Kimberly-Clark,
they said it's not driving a shortage
but it's certainly limiting options.
- [Carter] But it wasn't
just limited access
to raw materials that have
driven up diaper prices.
Throughout the pandemic,
ongoing shipping issues due
to a surge on online
orders, COVID restrictions,
and driver shortages have
caused significant delays
across the US.
This has impacted deliveries
across industries,
including diapers, which has caused
freight costs to balloon.
- You have the trucking
rates, the labor for drivers,
the equipment that needs to
be maintained and replaced,
even the insurance costs.
So producers are seeing
significant increases recently
in overall transportation costs.
- [Carter] Diapers, unlike some other
smaller personal care items,
are impacted more by shipping costs
due to the product's bulky size.
- The vast majority of diaper production
in the US is local.
There's a very, very small
percentage that is imported.
It's a highly, what they
call, volumetric product,
meaning that per dollar of sales,
it's expensive to ship.
And so it's largely
trucking transportation
within the US from the factories
to distribution centers
and ultimately through
retail channel partners.
- [Carter] Still, there's one other factor
affecting the price of diapers
that has been trending for years.
In the US, births have
been steadily dropping
for the past decade.
The number of babies born in
2020 dropped by 4% compared
with the previous year,
partially driven by a trend
of women choosing to have
fewer children later in life.
- As the birth rate declines,
it has an instant effect on diaper sales
because babies need diapers
the minute they're born.
So if there's fewer babies born,
it's not some products
where 10 years down the road,
a smaller population might trickle down.
If fewer babies are born in 2020,
diaper sales go down in 2020.
- [Carter] To make up
for lower diaper sales,
companies have increased prices
to partially fill the gap.
- To offset this decline in birth rate,
the companies are trying
to basically sell more expensive diapers
that are nicer diapers.
So that competition has
become more intense.
There's more organic diapers.
There's a lot of features in diapers now
that didn't exist 10 years ago.
- [Carter] As diaper
prices have increased,
for many working families,
the financial strain has added to a list
of growing expenses.
- The need in 2021 seems
to be almost as high or
higher as it was in 2020.
So even as the economy's recovering,
it's not going back to 2019 levels.
- [Carter] Experts like David Garfield say
that even if commodity and
shipping costs come back down,
because of increased margins,
diaper price increases
will likely stay inflated
for the near future.
(lively music)